our last story today women ruin
everything women ruin everything really
we've ruined the work force we even
ruined women's sport by whining and
complaining about her pay and now we're
ruining gyms yes ruining gyms there was
a woman that decided to make a skit how
women are just ruining the gym let's
pull it up hey guys this is a tutorial
on how to make a guy look like a creep
in the gym first I like to set up the
barbell in the free weight area directly
in front of my Victim wearing tiny
shorts then I start doing rdls for him
to see that [__] fat and grab his
attention I'll then my workout turn
around and confront him about perving on
me making sure I'm getting all of this
on camera next I'll green screen my
video and talk about how I feel violated
and then post on my social media so I
receive comments from other girls saying
go sis see you next time and so she's
making fun of this but she's right